[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot we
are here what time is it it's almost
noon pacific time we're getting ready
for the Microsoft press conference over
in Cologne Germany around 9 o'clock p.m.
their time Justin hey well what's up you
don't have to lie we're actually in
Cologne Germany you can tell from the
background it's 9 p.m. we flew over last
night we yeah we have our UK team
they're over there they're covering from
the ground they'll be there all week
doing demos getting news from the
developers and the publishers that are
there for the week I think Microsoft
press conference probably the biggest
thing going on in terms of events over
there I mean that's why we're here right
yeah this is very early this is almost
III like Gamescom doesn't kick off until
I think Wednesday yeah but but here we
are on Sunday coming in to watch the
start of games come yeah I think we want
to talk about what we think we'll see
today we have the YouTube and the twitch
chats open for you if you're watching on
GameSpot YouTube or twitch but yeah
we'll be live-streaming this for the
duration I think it's gonna be like an
hour and a half conference so go till
1:30 Pacific like 10:30 I've heard
roughly it's gonna be out okay so kind
of a lengthy one especially for for the
UK guys because I mean this is the night
time for them yeah so I think they just
got settled in Cologne this morning I'm
not mistaken maybe yesterday yeah we
have our like I said our UK teams over
there they'll have more stories coming
out they have a couple press days before
the conference starts or they just
hanging out until Wednesday yeah so
games come is kind of set up the way the
TGS is where the start of the show is
something for a press and Industry and
it is focused on letting you see stuff a
little bit early if you're part of the
industry or part of the press and then
it opens up to the public so though the
weekend is gonna be a little bit crazy
and I've heard really like I've heard
some interesting stories about games
come on the weekend yeah I went last
year remind people make it this year but
was it a lot of people it makes III look
at tiny are you said you're not there
this year no I thought the UK team is
covering it but yeah the German food it
was good for a night I like German food
but after a while it gets to be filling
Frankie the G on YouTube
saying what games we're expecting to see
so that's probably as good as segways I
need to go into what we expect just last
week I believe they announced crackdown
3 delay once again so they get safe to
say we probably won't see anything from
them I don't know it doesn't mean we
won't ever see it
yeah maybe they'd like to show some
goodwill like hey we're still working on
it they uh we're gonna I think we got
Eric Tai here he's gonna pull up
crackdown 3 we're seeing the Terry Crews
III trailer coming up in a second but
yeah I wonder if they would just lay low
and kind of stay out of the limelight or
if they would have something because I
mean it was just last week I announced
it delay so they must have known a
little bit ahead of time but maybe they
have something ready for people who are
kind of disappointed by that which I'm
sure is a lot of people because that was
like the flagship Xbox release right for
a little bit aside from what a couple
others we have a couple other big ones
sea of thieves I think is gonna have a
big presence at the show and that's
that's something I'm really excited
about I haven't played as much of the
Alpha as I'd like but it's it's such an
interesting concept like being on the
high seas being with like I mean and we
also have that kind of multiplayer
centric that gameplay which has really
kind of taken over the office with pub G
recently thieves seems like it might
capture that same kind of passion yeah
cuz I mean we got we saw a skull and
bones going cross skullenbones from
Ubisoft announced at e3 as well but
that's more combat oriented kind of
taking the Black Flag Assassin's Creed
for naval combat and bringing that to an
entire game and a multiplayer world but
yeah see if the eve seems like it's
going more for that kind of emergent
just like finding your own story kind of
stuff playing with three others
definitely more of a quirky tone kind of
comedic tone we also saw a lot of fours
at 7 at e3 and that comes out when
November is that sometime soon November
so I think that's the the yearly release
date for for Fortson yeah
force of seven looks really good as you
can expect they use that you know that
that hot trailer full of good-looking
cars to show off the Xbox one X which we
can talk about in a little bit but yeah
4 to 7 I'm not much of a sim kind of
racing guy but it looks gorgeous and I'm
sure I know people are excited for it
yeah I'm much more the the arcade racing
style the Forza horizon 3 well mariokart
mariokart yeah that too
4 to 7 we had a stage interview with e3
and they were saying you know
known for a while to specs to the Xbox
one X are there looking forward to
showing it off with this game
Ford acceptable definitely see I would
it would be weird not to especially
because I'm sure they'll be just like
putting even more emphasis on Xbox one X
after the e3 reveal just showing I mean
between like maybe going deeper into
specs that was right well that's the big
thing they said it III that they haven't
told us everything that they've held
some things back and I think there's
gonna be a big focus on X there's
obviously gonna be a big focus on Xbox
one X at Gamescom and I think finally
we're gonna learn how many scorpions are
in the box because I've been curious
about this how long you've been saving
that joke for no I use I've used it a
couple times I it's not a joke I'm I'm
pretty sure did you say did I hear you
say there's a special edition that says
project Scorpio on it so there there
have been a lot of leaks coming out it
wouldn't be a Microsoft press it
wouldn't be a press conference without
some leaks beforehand and one of them is
that there's apparently going to be a
special edition Xbox one X which says
project Scorpio on it and which might be
filled with scorpions but it's gonna be
especially branded and the outside of
the Xbox 1x looks pretty cool like it is
a a slightly different design Zoe yeah
well not sleek I think it's like a cut
textured kind of front it looks really
interesting it's yeah were they going
for that kind of mesh look of the s that
has like those it's like that I the
vented look it looks good and it's much
smaller obviously but um we also we're
talking about what's the what's the Ori
sequel called or in the blind lips
willow blowing wisps will whispering
willows whispering willows with took in
the toad totally willing Ori to I'm sure
maybe they'll show more of that off as
well they don't have many like again
like a wider conversation to have that
we've been having since the beginning of
the year since scalebound got cancelled
and there was no halo 6 announcement
this year which we know that's
eventually gonna come from 343 but there
was no announcement and now with
crackdown 3 release microsoft is really
gonna have to push I feel like there's
two ways they can go they can go for the
this is the best platform to play any
game on any third-party games like maybe
they'll show Assassin's Creed today
stuff like that and that's what they've
been doing with e3 right for since e3
right
didn't they don't have the biggest
exclusive catalogue or the most alluring
exclusive catalog so they've been trying
to push like if you want to play a third
party game that's on one or two
platforms and PC as well maybe even
switch the Xbox one X is the place to
play it do you think they'll pursue that
or do you think they'll try to I don't
know up there own exclusive game at all
which kind of is non-existent right now
well you're also hitting it at an
interesting time in the in the kind of
life cycle of the industry to get more
into that business side of it coming up
III is kind of that perfect time to
prime some holiday exclusives and the
things that are coming up the first
chance to look at stuff coming up with a
holiday right now like I think a lot of
like Microsoft and Sony really want to
focus on stuff coming up this holiday
they don't want people to forget that
kind of thing and that's why I think
Sony actually has a really good idea
with having their second event capping
in December because that's past the
holiday they don't have to focus on
those games coming up any more they can
show trailers for stuff coming up in the
next year yeah and right now Microsoft
be you know kinda is staying with this
type of conference it is gonna have to
be more focused on those holiday
releases and I think we're gonna see
that that that means there's gonna have
to be a focus on third parties yeah what
third party games do you think we'll see
I mentioned it's a Sanskrit origins Star
Wars Battlefront 2 I think we'll see
some of that yeah what stage was it that
they showed off battle I thought it was
the EA stage I don't know that Microsoft
or Sony showed anything off for
battlefront later in the week but
Microsoft is such a big player at
Gamescom like in the same way that Sony
dominated a lot of conversations during
e3 I think Microsoft gets to dominate
the show here because Sony doesn't have
a presence at Gamescom they're opting
out of the show entirely so Nintendo's
gonna be here but in a much smaller
capacity Microsoft really gets to be the
star of the show yeah Microsoft kind of
is like you kind of mentioned it's maybe
their last chance to throw a punch
before you know like they do have to
focus on holiday releases but at the
same time they can also look at other
third-party games to try to say this is
the best platform play on there just as
ins creed origins at e3 they were the
ones that after the teaser showed off a
little bit of anthem the new IP that was
long a rumor it's coming from Bioware
and I have to imagine they'd show
something from that right that would be
a huge you know inclusion in their show
if they were able to show it off that
would make this show really exciting
because I don't
think we're gonna get new games I don't
think we're gonna see the first time
like we're not gonna see you know halo
what six now like we're not gonna see
something that we've never ever seen
before but I think we will get a deeper
look at some games that we have seen and
I think there's also a really good
chance that Bethesda might show some
more stuff off here like they have a lot
of stuff coming up in the pipeline for
this holiday that Microsoft press
conference would be a good time to show
it running on Xbox one X yeah Bethesda
has Wolfenstein - that's October 27th
and that looks great we've got some
gameplay from that up people Kelly and
John Luke here in our office got to play
trial - dual wielding of the new guns
and whatnot and see the story that's set
in America with BJ returning to fight
Nazis here on occupied American soil I'm
assuming are you a Wolfenstein fan are
you looking forward to maybe seeing that
today I do I like they recaptured so
much of what made Wolfenstein fun with
with the always though the name of the
last game the new order the new order
like that really surprised and I think
that surprised a lot of us in the office
that we didn't expect it to be as good
as it was and it's much better than
deserve to be that makes you really
excited for that kind of sequel yeah and
that's the same game that's the same day
as Super Mario Odyssey on the switch and
assassin's creed origin on all platforms
but as far as Bethesda go is to go back
to that October 13th
a couple days after shadow of war which
maybe they'll show some of that off
middle of but going like evil within two
is when I'm mentioning from Bethesda and
you know people are excited for that
because I think the first game in 2014 I
believe the evil within it showed some
promise and some potential from the
Resident Evil creator Shinji Mikami and
he obviously was directing evil within
so from tango GameWorks we're looking
forward to maybe seeing more of that
like I said that'll be October 13th
shadow for a couple days before that
from Warner Bros and monolith for who
did shadow of Mordor also from 2014 we
have seen a lot of this game by now
actually and it actually made kind of
negative headlines recently with its
microtransactions what do you think of
those as far as being able to kind of
just skip stuff in the single-player
campaign if you pay real-world money hey
it's it's something that is optional is
it as much as I don't like that trend
towards microtransactions when it's
something you don't have to do like I
don't have a huge problem with it if
it's not something that
that's changing the experience for you
and especially when it's not multiplayer
if it's if you're not if it's not pay to
win I don't have a huge problem with it
yeah for those just joining we are here
live streaming getting ready for the
gamescom Microsoft press conference we
have our UK team over there we have
about a minute and a half until it goes
live over there 9:00 p.m. local time
here it's almost noon one more thing I
do want to add and we do have the
YouTube twitch and GameSpot chats open
if you're watching on the stream thank
you for joining us pub G I think they
would be dumb not to show that game just
crossed seven million copies sold
or was it seven okay but I like it seven
seven million which is huge especially
for just an early access game from a
team of a few people from Blue Hole over
in a Korea with Brandon green player
unknown kind of heading that stuff up
we've been playing this a ton in the
office on PC and it's a big it's a big
get for Microsoft to have it on the
console especially Xbox one X I mean I
think it's more tailor-made for PC
controls and I think it'll it'll always
be a bigger audience on the PC but Xbox
one X having it might be you know one of
those things that kind of really
flourishes on that console because you
can't play it anywhere else on consoles
right now and I think they have to show
it right I mean we've had so many of
these kind of similar multiplayer
experiences that I don't know if things
necessarily delivered on the way that
people expected Friday the 13th
Daisy pub G is something that I feel
like has really captured people's
imaginations in a surprising way it's
kind of like rocket League like it seems
kind of simple it's not something that
you would expect yet to be as big as it
is but but it just it's so much fun in
the moment and I think pub G really
captures that it seems like it would
just be this hardcore military shooter
thing for the PC crowd and right now
it's doing really well but I among many
other people have been captivated by it
we are about 10 seconds out so I we are
gonna toss it over to xbox stream if
you're watching on YouTube twitch or
GameSpot it's about to go live and we
have our UK team they're coming on the
ground so stay tuned the game spot to
watch the stream and for all the news
coming out of it throughout the week
thanks for joining
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in Germany whoa good job everyone if we
vote for you tonight world exclusive
GameTrailers new hardware edition
reveals new services coming to Europe
and of course we have a big pre-order
announcement so stay tuned yeah hats
this McCullen here in Cologne and that's
how we say it in German so on tonight's
show we've got exclusive news on the
hottest titles coming out soon for the
Xbox one family and Windows 10 PC but
it's not only going to be us talking
tonight now we have an amazing line-up a
special gas it flew in from all over the
globe oh yeah that's right plus if
you're watching on mixer and siding on
your XP or Microsoft account you'll have
the chance to get your questions
answered and be with the running to win
some exclusive swag like these special
design lab controllers but later on in
fact every single person watching on
mixer and logged in with their Microsoft
account will receive the Xbox games comm
mix pot which wait for it includes the
t15 new recruit kit for World of Tanks
the commander's bonus Supply Drop for
battle islands commanders and the custom
war paint DLC for Halo Wars 2 and breeze
now I know some of you at home are
probably thinking hold on somebody's
missing let's all have a moment of
silence for major this year but it's not
the same without Major Nelson so I think
if you stick around you'll be making a
very special appearance later in the
show so somewhere in the building my
shoulder the whole show now expecting
talk about games okay what's your
favorite things about game school
I think war games come of course for me
is all about the gamers so III kind of
like the big announcement game's
comments when everyone gets their hands
on so you have all the flashy trailers
blah blah blah you can't again
you really get to see what it's all
about because it's about the fans and
that's great I love it how about you
might say this is like home territory
thank you for having us in your
beautiful thank you so much for coming
and it's like I mean Gamescom you're
right it's all about the fans I think it
was 350,000 last year so I'm gonna hope
we're gonna jump on to that number so
I'm really excited not to probably meet
everyone shake a lot of hand so talk
about games along yes but there's a lot
going on at Gamescom you have like
cosplayers I want to check out like Xbox
fan fests their concerts there's so much
going on around cologne so I love our
Xbox booth looks absolutely amazing this
year you'll see much more of that later
this week there's so much gaming
goodness to look forward to over the
next week right here in Cologne but
right now let's turn our attention to
what's in store over the next hour and a
half on Xbox at Gamescom live like your
world premieres we've got you covered
with seven yes count em seven world
premiere trailers for you to feast your
eyes on we will be bringing loads of
Xbox one X enhanced games for you to
check out love minecraft then oh boy do
we have a treat in store this is the
place to be for the latest updates on
forts or more sports 7 state of decay -
sea of thieves where unknowns
battlegrounds and much more Plus stay
tuned for that crucial Xbox one X
pre-order info and another very special
announcement
this is Xbox at Gamescom live anyway
right now I'm joined by Jean Yadav who's
a creative director from Ubisoft to show
us the latest from an assassin's creed
origins cause it was amazing to have you
guys with us at e3 now what's happened
since then what's kind of the feedback
been like what's going on well firstly
no III was a moment really special for
us you know first being on stage was
quite intimidating but the entire team
you know it was a very important moment
we were working for month three three
and a half years on this game
and reading the game finally was a
really really intense since then where
we are really happy about the reaction
so far seeing people you know getting
excited and wanting to play to play the
game we are listening to the first
feedbacks and actually keep pushing you
know until the the final line yeah so
you've taken Assassin's Creed ancient
Egypt it's a really fascinating time in
history tell us more about that
well yes we we thought you know that's a
time sure that we really wanted to do
for a long time we knew science also
wanted it and it was the perfect setting
for us to really tell this origin story
the story of the creation of the
Brotherhood as we know it since I see
one and so this was really a forest the
the next step and the good place where
to go basically nice I believe you have
something to show us
yes actually for Gamescom we thought
that would the perfect thing to brought
to you with our new brand-new CGI
trailer we know people actually enjoy
them and so it really loose rates you
know the time period Egypt with the the
clash of civilizations the ascension to
the throne of queen Cleopatra okay cool
so that's right everybody it's time for
the first of our exclusive trailers take
a look at this world premiere CGI
trailer for Assassin's Creed origins
premiere from here
[Music]
if thine is the glory then mine must be
the shame you want a darker we kill the
faith
five movie name is a fire crucified
didn't it you can frame burning for the
help okay
you wanted darker
oh really
the story but the story still the same
there's a love of suffering and of
pirate dogs to blame in the scriptures
and it's not some idle claim you want it
darker we kill the flame
there's I've heard about the prisoners
and the guards who take anything
us for some tea they were middle class
and II didn't know
you wanna darker
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Bono's I was I was playing Assassin's
Creed historical face bingo on my card
here Julius Caesar Ptolemy and I've got
Cleopatra coming out you know games
that's that's exactly why we love
working on this essence we you know
being able to recreate these time
periods it's always really really
interesting and and fun a couple of
things from the trailer that you spotted
sorry yeah but I think the trailer the
illustrates well actually what we want
players to do feel and to experience
when playing the game they will be part
of these very important historical
moments you know the actions of my egg
and the players will actually care and
and make the change that change the
world face basically like TMZ of history
you know like when you're gonna go
forward in time and like do a Kardashian
one or something like developing
Assassin's Creed origins for Xbox one X
or you know as a game developer having
the chance to develop for a new hardware
like egg box when X is really something
that is a thrilling because for us it's
really the way to deliver fully you know
the original vision we have talking
about graphics but also story the
mechanics the systems we know that
having more power will be will will make
our life easier and and being able to
bring more to the players well you don't
have to compromise right you don't have
to pick one thing over the other you can
have all right yeah that's the beauty of
working on xbox when X is that we it's
visually stunning but not not only you
know and so we we were also able to make
the gameplay evolve with the AI the
story the quest etcetera
we were talking earlier about how you've
got longer draw distances you can have
your your shading differently as yeah
actually improves gameplay in a way
right it is and even I mean the game
will look stunning you know and be fun
on all platforms but that's for sure
that the extra power of the Xbox 1x
really will let our players experience
the most beautiful version of it you
know the stunning details beautiful
landscapes incredible cities rendered in
both 4k and 1080p wait to see an
exponent so as the most important
question is when can we play it so
science with origins will be available
on Xbox one October 27th and be
compatible next books when X at the
launch of the console and November 7th
that's ok so we can't wait to see more
of this one I think myself and gray
definitely on that one
in fact one of you could be the lucky
owner of a collector's edition of the
game just take a look at this it's
amazing so cool
that's amazing just make sure you're
tuned in via mixer and of course signed
in with your Microsoft account and
you're just automatically entered just
for watching which is cool next up we'll
be trying the last man standing in
player unknowns battlegrounds right
after this
[Applause]
to Cologne is the player unknown himself
Brandon green welcomes we have such an
honor to have you oh thanks so much for
having me really cool so battlegrounds
obviously it's one of the hottest games
right now in the PC gaming room so how
did this get I'll start it so I was
living in Brazil and got back into
gaming by me or by way of the dayz mod'
and decided to see if I could make my
own mod and brands was formed and then
at Blue Hole Quebec or connected with me
last year yeah move to Korea and like a
few months ago right four months ago so
I'd really have to say the slowly
because this number is really amazing
you sold over 8 million copies yeah we
just passed last week no no it's good
that we don't process it you know we've
just keep us focused on development it's
like so from your own perspective what
do you think like what makes this game
so popular not sure I think it's like
the idea that it's just a very basic
game it's like land loose survived and
everyone can understand that and I think
that's what the draw is that there's no
rules there's no you have to play this
way it's just you can jump in and play
and whatever way you want to do if you
want to win with a pan you go ahead yeah
I mean it's very straightforward you can
play too anyways like just get everybody
right dude do what you got to do just
tell everybody that there's a guy's
toast he's a hearthstone streamer he
said when his mom and dad watch him play
they don't understand what's going on I
mean obviously you know you've create
this game and everyone's gonna play
however they want what's kind of the
craziest weirdest thing you've seen in
the game there was a clip of a guy
spectating his friend and he had like 1
hp and he was being shot at I think I
said use the pan and he pulls out the
parents wings
oh yeah get behind the tree heals
himself just the chance of like a small
chance but it happens all the time it's
that's so cool that would never happen
to me I'll be running around just for
the scope or like about the origin of
winner winner chicken dinner yes please
oh so I just like the term it's like
when I was moving to ARMA 3 I just
needed a new winner slogan I love winner
winner chicken dinner now I think it
comes from Vegas where if you want a
poker hand you get 5 bucks which was a
chicken dinner so it was when I went
that did say when I was out so easy with
you like hard for yours to be honest
like we really admire you for what
you've done
so yes it's exactly I mean when we're
going back to e3 you announced is also
coming to xbox right now it's on PC
maybe tell us when no we don't want to
give like an exact day but we're coming
at the end towards the end of this year
and like we're coming to Xbox game
preview which is great because it allows
us to develop with the community get
real player feedback on like how the
controller feels and how movement feels
and all this and using that with the
game preview program is is invaluable to
us for development it makes sense yes
and can you maybe just dive a little
more about the Xbox and ambition behind
this oh yeah so we want to get basically
the PC version and the Xbox version the
same experience on both platforms and
today we want to announce that we're
partnering with Microsoft we want to
publish onto Xbox with Microsoft and
what that means is that they now give us
the wealth of their knowledge and
experience to help us make the console
first and better and faster I mean
that's amazing of course it just means
what everyone's gonna get a better game
but also you kept you get some good
perks obviously now you're their compass
and got some life things yes but no it's
great because this publishing deal it
means that you know as I said we get all
the knowledge the Microsoft have well we
still retain control over
development and design decisions that's
like the players gonna be happy with
that you know that Microsoft are great
and they're a great heart to work with
cool I mean you go got loads of stuff
obviously happening at Gamescom this
week the first ever fight on own
invitationals which i feel it's gonna be
slightly madcap and slightly insane I
mean in a good way
yeah can you tell us anything about that
a little bit so like we have I think 80
of the best battle royale player is
coming from all over the world we're
flying them in like crazy we have this
really cool set built for them it's like
we yeah we have some crazy players that
like get insane shots and they just
they're very good at what they do
so we're gonna be live on mixer calm
people and we'll be live for three days
we'll have solos duo's squads and even
some first-person action so I can't wait
it's going to be awesome really and I
can learn a thing or two maybe from yes
pro players yeah it's a great game to
watch and like just so much because you
learn things from these players just by
watching the game which is great that's
true so we really have a lot to look
forward to and thank you so much for
coming here coming to : I wish you a lot
of fun at Gamescom and I can't wait for
battle grounds coming to Xbox one
definitely thank you and in just a
second we'll be talking all things Xbox
with Aaron greenberg and Shannon Loftus
but before we get to that we've got
another exclusive for you with plenty
more still to come of course
let's take a look I'm just gonna say
this slowly because I'm a little bit
excited to the world from your trailer
for Jurassic world evolution Dylan and
why is no one else doing that
I'm trying me world premiere
control
[Music]
[Music]
there you go folks that's another world
premiere trailer for you that is
Jurassic world evolutions now we're
joined by Shannon Loftus and Aaron
Greenberg from Xbox
[Applause]
welcome to the show it's great to have
you here in Germany we love Gamescom
taught me we do fun here yes so we've
got tons of stuff to get through and an
amazing line-up of games to talk through
as well but Aaron first of all tell me
what does Gamescom mean to you because I
know you know we've repeats games come
up into a few this is absolutely one of
my very favorite shows because it is the
biggest consumer gaming show in Europe
and for us this is a big year for games
for us at e3 we showed the largest most
diverse lineup of games we've ever had
and we're taking all those games here
plus we have a lot more we're showing in
fact I just checked our booth here we
have 70 playable stations of Xbox 1x
nice first time that's been playable for
fans in Europe and so we're excited just
to share all the great games and from us
and our partners that's really exciting
so we talked to e3 about our games
lineup there was tons of good stuff in
there you know do you have some updates
for our fans about our games lineups
looking yeah it's growing really well I
mean of course let's remember we're the
only system design with backward
compatibility in mind you can now play
with the addition of the original Xbox
games three generations of games all on
one system we have over 400 titles
available and backward compatibility
today and we're adding more every day
and we've also talked about enhanced
games for Xbox one x3 remind us about
some of them and maybe sprinkle in a few
new ones that we can expect well of
course some people saw the specs of Xbox
one X and all the power and the ability
to do true 4k gaming they said or are
you gonna take any of the games that I
own and make enhancements and so within
Microsoft Studios we're going back and
making games like Gears of War for
updating it in true 4k with HDR we're
doing the same for a bunch of our other
titles adding 4k upgrades these are free
4k upgrades so if you enforce a horizon
3 you own minecraft you own Killer
Instinct Halo Wars 2 all those titles
we're gonna update for you for free nice
so other games as well right there's
deaf sorry you're right I have some more
fans after that's great but we would
love what about halo 5 well the team at
343 decided to share is going back and
updating halo 5 in 4k as well and one of
my personal favorite games from last
year a masterpiece that Shannon and her
team actually gave to us quantum break
will be another free 4k upgrade as part
of our enhanced program that's great use
quantum break looked amazing anyway it's
gonna be incredible and Xbox one X -
more in 4k is a dish is for sure so not
only remedy got their hands on a def kit
also we have a lot of other partners
that have a deaf kid at their students
what are they having a stock response
has been great you know we obviously
made sure we got our deaf kits out to
folks as soon as possible with a couple
months and we've already seen an
incredible response in fact we have a
program for all these titles now that
their Xbox one X enhanced you'll see it
on the box and we're in fact today going
to release our first list of total
titles that are committed to do
enhancements for Xbox one X take
advantage of the power take advantage of
all those benefits and so all the
biggest games frankly are doing if
you're a fan of FIFA 18 that will be
enhanced if you're a star Wars fan
Star Wars Battlefront 2 will be enhanced
pub G another title that will be
enhanced of course and so NBA 2k
Wolfenstein - all the biggest titles of
the year shadow of war another towel on
that list but the thing I love is it's
not just the new titles also existing
games are going back so titanfall 2 will
be getting the treatment as well as well
as fallout 4 so a lot of games whether
you own them or maybe you didn't get a
chance to play them if you have an Xbox
one X you're gonna have another reason
to put those games back in and check out
all these new enhancements and if you
own those games already that's free
right you don't need to pay extra for
those enhancement absolutely these are
free upgrades for fans amazing alright
so Shannon I mean you're the head of
publishing at Microsoft which means you
probably know one or two games that may
be coming out so do you do we have some
news on that we do we are coming off of
a monster III where we got to show off
brand new gameplay in the campaign for
crackdown 3 we
gave everybody update on what's
happening inside state of decay - and of
course we announced the tear jerker Ori
and the will of the West it was great
but guess what got an announcement right
now
go on back it's over there
worry you're safe with us
hi Brandon core maintenance tool Adams
atmospherics
I'm glad I'm not alone out
Oh
get out here you've got to
[Music]
[Applause]
I like that footage all right what I've
just seen and my hot clothes when I see
the little Mack like this woman go back
and play with him he tells a little bit
more about that
I think the trailer covered a ton my
favorite was always violet and you learn
a lot more about violated night in the
new massive expansion the cool thing
really though about this expansion is
that if you're already a reacquire
customer it's free for you oh yeah games
coming out August 20 nights all right so
if you have slept on record this is the
perfect time to get on board as amazing
to see all those enhancements there if
you guys are whom are watching on mixer
you're automatically in with a chance of
getting your hands on the game because
we're giving away 100 copies Wow just
make sure you're watching mixer via
Microsoft account for a chance to win it
is that simple so if I made this say
that's just on all behalf of German
gamers welcome again to Jeremy I'm have
you guys and I can say like we're kind
of the PC gaming home home for PC gaming
in Europe so and I know there's some
event happening tomorrow or regarding
Age of Empires can you give us a little
sneak peek on that wine really enjoy
plant and tomorrow we are celebrating
the 20th anniversary of Age of Empires
we're going to have a stream at exactly
this time and we're gonna show you quite
a bit more about Age of Empires 1
definitive edition and then we might
just have a major announcement to make
so you guys really really really want to
tune in tomorrow it's gonna be 5
actually seen this set and it looks
incredible what else do we have
PC gamers have a lot to look forward to
all of our biggest Microsoft Studios are
bringing their large their hit
franchises to Windows 10 in a huge way
and because they're all built on Xbox
Live
you can cross play between Windows 10
pcs and
there was one announcement last week
that might have slid under the radar a
little bit we announced that we're
bringing Rise of Nations which is an
absolutely beloved realtime strategy
game that's currently on Steam we're
bringing that to Windows 10 and guess
what we've unlocked cross network play
between Steam players and Windows 10
players we got a great lineup we have a
really diversity diverse lineup as well
so what else do we have like this
holiday for gamers
well xbox is a place where everyone can
have fun and we're actually in our fifth
holiday now with Xbox and every new
holiday brings a new kind of gamer
people this year are asking us what kind
of games can i play with my family with
my kids so I'm super super thrilled to
be announcing that we've taken some of
our most beloved family titles
we've remastered them and we're bringing
Disneyland adventures
ruch a disney pixar adventure and zoo
tycoon out on October 31st of this year
in 4k HD and HDR these titles have all
been enhanced with new content and you
can actually play every single one of
these on both controller and on Kinect
cool my kids are gonna love that it's a
great value speaking of my kids they
watch some of the three stuff and they
loved Super Lucky's tale lucky is he's
doing great he's still optimistic and
he's still really happy what I love most
about lucky and I get to play these
games before they release which is one
of the great perks of my job is that he
is it's a game that gives you the
traditional kind of platformer feeling
but because of the power of the Xbox the
world is completely alive it's very
modern in that everywhere you go there's
a ton of action there are characters
that are doing their own kind of thing
and they'll stop and interact with you
it's such a beautiful game I'm excited
it's coming on November 7th great a ton
of action is also happening in Halo and
we have really a lot of Halo fans here
in Europe what do we have for them well
for Halo or two fans which we know did
very well on the PC especially here in
Germany we have a whole new expansion
called awakening the nightmare
and this is not just your normal
expansion because this has got a whole
new campaign a whole story you play
through the opposite perspective as the
banished and so new blur cinematic
something I'm really excited I love the
story from Halo Wars to and continue
that but of course for multiplayer we've
got new things like new leaders new maps
determinists firefight mode that's
really designed with co-op in mind and
you get to take on an ancient you know
you can take on the flood so it's gonna
be just a lot of great stuff for Halo
fans and that's coming in 4k with HDR on
September 26 so I really love the
firefight feature that's like one of my
favorites and it's also a lot of content
that you just announced there and when
we're talking about a lot of stuff a lot
of stuff is also happening it's being
passed right yes Xbox game past is
probably the best game valuing gave me
yeah we launched it in June for $9.99
you get over a hundred games you can
download and play we're expanding that
to eight new markets and we're actually
adding seven new titles this month
including record affinity actually dirt
rally just went into Xbox game passes
well one of my favorite games from last
year so you should definitely check that
like to celebrate the expansion of Xbox
game pass we're giving away game pass
codes so get over to mixer now if you're
not already watching there you should be
make sure you're signed in to your
Microsoft account and you're
automatically entered just for watching
nice so for a lot of gamers Aaron they
are focused on exclusives
well of course people pick Xbox because
we have the biggest franchises the
biggest exclusives whether you're a fan
of Halo or Gears of War or or Forza this
holiday personally you know Xbox one
I'm really excited Xbox won't be the
only console where you can play Forza
Motorsport 7
cuphead and pub G so really excited
about that also tied with the Xbox one X
launch we have super Lucky's tale it's
another exclusive but it doesn't stop
there because into the spring we have
sea of thieves state of decay to and
crackdown 3 so we're basically non-stop
hitting our fans with more and more
exclusive titles so it'll be tons of
great games to play but of course we
know people want great big walk Buster
games
and they want them enhanced for Xbox one
X we want games that will take advantage
of that 40% power advantage that's 60
percent memory advantage I'm excited to
announce that we have over 100 titles
that we are with our partners announcing
will be enhanced for Xbox one X and so I
think the great thing is a gamer is no
matter if you're a fan of RPGs or sports
games or shooters whatever your type of
game is your these games are going to
look and play better on Xbox one x
amazing you can check out that list
right now right if you're head over to
Major Nelson com that's where we're
putting it that's what Larry's been
doing he couldn't make it to games we've
gotten that list really Shannon Aaron
fantastic we covered a lot of ground
there I'm gonna try and recap it right
so the quiz yeah you can correct me if I
get anything wrong here over 100 titles
enhanced for Xbox one X and you can
check out that way that's today we were
at 40 83 so by launch the list will keep
growing fantastic record definitive
edition announced and it's coming to
Xbox game personal history ninth we
talked about those enhanced family
titles as well Shannon and super Lucky's
tale is coming soon too and we've got an
amazing Age of Empires event tomorrow
night with more news and lots of great
stuff for PC gamers coming up as well
game passing new markets as well why not
thank you so much don't wait to spend
more time you this week alone right now
it's time to take to the track with
forts or more a sports 7 my favorite
let's take a look at the danger and the
beauty of competitive racing at the
limit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like this super shiny and there's like
SuperDuper shoddy it makes my heart do
funny things every time I see that
really I can feel it from here
moderately vibrating the presence of
bill of course we're joined by Bill GZ
from 10 studio so first of all welcome
to the show thank you so much for
joining us really appreciate that and
yeah you've been really busy lately a
lot of new car announces can you track
announcer yeah yeah Nurburgring is is
you know a show-off Nurburgring which is
great because we're here in Germany
being able to see that dynamic weather
it's awesome very good so we know
reports there's a huge franchise on Xbox
already but we've got lots of PC news
today right yeah okay through that time
so this is the first four to built from
the ground up for PC and it's an epic PC
title got 700 cars dynamic weather
dynamics sky so every time you go to a
track it's different a massive new a
motorsport inspired campaign mode it'll
be on you know PC native 4k and an
unlocked framerate for those high-end
pcs and for us you know we've got a huge
community of players you know words it
has over five million active monthly
players and with four to seven we're
gonna be bringing you know all those
passionate console players and all the
passionate PC players into one place
that's so cool
I mean you guys at Ford sir
[Music]
you're quite literally bubble measurers
[Music]
no I mean it's a good thing you want you
want that kind of level of detail but I
was just kind of wondering like what's
the sort of weirdest thing that's
happened making game because I feel like
you've got some probably good stories
they're more than I mean people think
about developing games you just sitting
in an office today but no our team
capture team they've done some crazy
things when we went out to go capture
the 911 gt2 RS the the first one that
came off the line Porsche actually took
down to South Africa because they were
gonna do all their marketing materials
they were gonna capture it all there
yeah we sent our team down there that
was the first time we got to see it and
as
they're out there taking pictures all of
a sudden the Porsche representative just
starts covering the cars he's like nope
and now in the distance we could see
these drones flying in because people
had heard Porsche was there and they
wanted to get the scoop right they had
to wait 45 minutes for the batteries to
die for these drones to fall pull it off
again and then they were able to capture
the car you telling sister about Dubai
yes yes so we went to Dubai obviously
you know is it chilly a hundred and
twenty degrees to capture reference
there we melted to twenty five hundred
dollar cameras because it was so hot
melted melted hard work goes into a game
there you know we know it looks
incredible by Xbox one X and on high
spec pcs as well right but not everyone
has a beast gaming PC right right if
I've got like a mid or a lower spec PC
the last few years the fort's of tech
engines been on PC we had four to six
apex sports of horizon three and in that
time as we've been working on the engine
over over time we've been able to lower
our min spec to an i5 750 okay in fact
at the office I play it on a surface pro
4 yeah and you know not only that a
recommended spec has been lowered as
well and it still runs at a rock-solid
60 frames per second you know we really
wanted to bring you know all the
millions more players that are on mid to
lower inspect machines bring them into
the four to fold so I mean obviously
most players of Fortson would probably
use a controller but there are some out
there you know you do like their
peripherals what can you tell us about
that for first well we've got over 30
officially supported wheels which is
really cool but with multi USB support
you can take any of the boutique wheels
or pedal sets you have and they can mix
and match up when we started to build it
you know we the entire team got so
excited we brought in all these USB
peripherals that we could find from
flight sticks to fightsticks i've even
raced four to seven on a guitar hero
guitar drum set dance pad yeah
I obviously probably wasn't very that
fast but the point is is you know
players won't use that stuff but
whatever you got laying around in your
closet you can just plug it in and play
and after the stream today people can go
check out a xbox wire and they can see
are officially a full list of official
peripherals and they can see our PC
specs all right fantastic remaining this
one forward somewhat sports sevens going
to be available bill the deluxe and
standard edition will come out October
3rd and then for Ultimate editions
players they actually get to play at
four days early on September 29th so
they can feel superior thank you very
much to see it and I don't forget that
you can go to Xbox where right now and
you can get all of that PC for it some
more sports 7 information right there so
there's no doubt it's gonna look amazing
on a high spec gaming PC but of course
it will also look stunning in true 4k on
the Xbox 1x and fans attending Gamescom
right here in Cologne this week we'll be
able to get hands-on and see for
themselves how beautiful it is
that's boiler alert it looks amazing I
would say distractingly beautiful almost
to the fact that it makes me drive
terribly absolutely I might just be a
tell and of course there's lots more
exciting announcements coming up on the
show including shadow of war sea of
thieves and we've got something very
special for all you Minecraft fans and
don't forget we've got that big
pre-order announcement coming soon so
stay tuned but first let's take a closer
look at the most powerful console in the
world of saying the Xbox 1x
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
well we're joined by Micah borrow from
Xbox platform engineer and Mike thank
you for coming on the show and what a
year for Xbox so far
that's always great to be here at
Gamescom there's so much energy and
excitement I just can't wait for the
week so we just saw the trailer for Xbox
one exit building and people will be
able to play it that games come this
week how important is that for you yeah
I mean it's a huge milestone for us in
fact the first time people in Europe
will be able to play xbox 1x here at
Gamescom in fact if you look at Xbox 1s
Windows 10 pcs and Xbox 1x
we'll have over 170 stations for people
to play the best versions of the games
we're really excited a question that's
been on my mind and people are asking me
as well if I've already got an Xbox one
or an Xbox one s and I'm adding an Xbox
one X to the family how easy are we
making that transition to the new
console yeah a lot of the feedback we
had was to make that easy for people and
so there's three things we're really
doing the first is we want to make sure
that the settings on an existing Xbox
can transfer over to Xbox one XO will
provide a very easy way to do that and
Aaron announced over 100 games with Xbox
1x enhancements and so one of the things
we want to do is for some of those games
get you all of those updates before Xbox
1 X launches so that when you get your
Xbox 1 X you plug it in and you're in
those awesome amazing games which would
be really incredible the third thing
we're doing is if you add an Xbox to
your home we're gonna let you coffee
games and apps off your home network
instead of having to manually move them
or redownload them from the internet so
people's ability to copy those from Xbox
Xbox would be a big big feature too and
if I've got a ton of games on an
external HDD I can just plug that into
my X right yeah you and I have external
drives ah yeah that's just a matter of
unplugging it from one plugging it into
the X and all your games are ready to
play a lot of time so it really makes it
easy for me to just jump into the Xbox
one X right yeah and also the system
update is in preview right now so what
can we talk about there yeah I mean it's
in preview right now this is an update
across the entire Xbox family of devices
and we're really happy over the rats at
there's so many features that we take a
long time to go through them but a
couple of those is right when you bit up
you'll notice a brand new home and so
with home we always focus on speed and
performance and so what's the fastest
home that we've ever had in addition to
that we focus on discovery we want
people to easily find other gamers to
play with so for example if Graham is
broadcasting on mixer I'll see it right
on home and I can watch what he's
playing or Maxie if you have a looking
for group up you're looking for more
players in Halo 5 I'll see that popping
their game so bringing people together
is important for us and one of the
biggest things we've had a lot of
feedback on is they want to make people
want to make home theirs they want a
personalization of that and so we're
introducing content box with content
blocks I can pin people I can pin you
and Graham on there I can pin games
clubs and it's easy access for me to see
everything that's going on from the
developer from the achievements that
you're getting and keep that dialogue
but it's really about gamer choice so if
I want a minimalistic home of just one
screen I can have that or I can have
pages of pinned items to really engage
with the community so personalization is
a big effort for us as well their brand
new guide second thing is a brand new
guide that we're doing optimized for
speed and layout you'll notice instead
of vertical we've moved it moved it to
horizontal so people can get to what
they want to very fast and stay in their
games which is a big big element and an
all new redesigned community tab and so
the Activity Feed that you have being
able to see like comment on what's going
on and more importantly more gamer
choice being able to filter that
Activity Feed so I can if I don't want
to see Graham and what he's doing I can
remove here so more customization and
personalization options to give people
the choice of how they want the system
to work for them nice and you've got a
cool new feature to show us for the
first time yeah that's right
we're adding a light mode to the console
and so today when you boot up it's in
dark mode we'll have a light mode as
well and we'll keep dark mode users can
choose which one they want to use but
the light mode is something I really
like it's very inviting it's very easy
to navigate and again you can choose
darker light whatever mode you want
that'll hit the builds very soon it's
really cool loads of people have asked
me about that
great to see ya so mixture has become a
really big part for Xbox and I see you a
lot I'm like sir I see ya a lot of
chicken dinners I saw Brandon here
awesome announcement that were published
in the console version of that game I've
been known to stream that a little bit
I'll be here at Gamescom all week live
streaming off mixer create app on iOS
and Android and so that's still in beta
when that launches we're gonna actually
have native not just live streaming but
also game streaming on both those
platforms so the best mobile games can
then be watched right off of mixer
natively love that so loads of new
features I'm sure there's tons more to
come as well right yeah I mean there's
so many features coming stop by the
mixer booth at Gamescom and our booth to
see them I want to thank all of the
people helping us test the update
without that feedback you know we
co-create that together so keep it
feedback coming and we're really happy
for this week yes much love to the
insiders feedback is very important and
thank you so much for telling all these
news to us and since we talked about pop
G it's all about survival and we have
another game that's also all about
survival let's take a look at state of
decay two
[Music]
the world he knew was gone how would you
protect yourself and the ones you love
from the terror just outside the walls
in this world of the living and the dead
how will you go by it's gonna taste like
rotting flesh welcome thank you glad to
be here so if anybody you know a half
state of decay past the vine I really
really recommend playing the first one
I'm back combat I just did it recently
but just can you just tell us really
quick what's it all about
yeah Stata decay is it's all about your
own survival fantasy you know we wanted
to make a game that captured that part
of the zombie genre that was you and
your friends sitting around at the pub
after a good zombie flick and kind of
talking about your own personal survival
plans and so the games built around that
would give you the tools to go tell your
own survival story and see how you do I
love post-apocalyptic stories right so
tell me how did we get into the into
this mess how did we get into the
apocalypse and stay of Decatur well
that's something you have to find out as
a player we revealed a couple of hints
along the way and the original and the
sequel will be revealing a lot more but
it's still not exactly clear what
happened or how it happened and that's
something for the players to figure out
fair enough so when you were developing
the game like what did you get the guys
inspired by well you know at the time we
were think we've been thinking about
this game for I mean more than a decade
and you know at the time there was this
kind of really good crop of three
emergence of zombie movies there was the
28 days later or 28 weeks later and then
even movies like zombie land and Shaun
of the Dead that brought a little bit of
humor to it and what what really became
apparent to all of us who were working
on this was that you know the zombie
genre was not about going around and
shooting and killing zombies it's about
it's about the people the connections of
the people who are surviving how they
work together you know even like a movie
like zombie land that's really a car
buddy movie right you know and so
there's just all this expressiveness in
it and we wanted to capture that that
width and breadth of the genre and not
just the how do you kill zombies so will
we maybe see a Twinkie
well Twinkie is a trademarked name and
probably not but you will definitely
find Easter eggs hidden throughout the
game that call back to some of the great
moments from from the zombie genre
through some of the new features in
state of decay to that you know maybe
stay at decay fans will be excited to
get our primary goal was to really take
what worked in the first one and just
double down on it we came up with a
really unique formula the kind of third
person action married with the really
deep RPG progression the mechanics for
your character is the base building and
then put that all in a simulated
open-world and that that formula really
resonated and really did well and so
what we wanted to do was just take that
deep into each of those systems and and
really just deepen the survival fantasy
but in addition all that we added the
number one fan requested feature which
was cooperative multiplayer so in state
of decay - you're finally gonna be able
to play with your friends which is
something we've been looking forward to
for a long time one of the things I
loved about state to kaiba also caused
me a lot of pain as well was perma death
are you bringing that back into the case
oh it's core to the experience
absolutely you know there is no sense of
threat there is no sense of consequences
for your actions if there's not death in
the game it's it's part it's hard to
imagine making a zombie game that
doesn't really have a permadeath but you
know the important thing for us is that
if you die in the game you can always
look at it and say if only I had done
this differently or that differently
right we never want you to think the
game just arbitrarily decided it was
time for you to die or or you know kind
of cheesed it right it has to be because
of something you did and that's the
contract we make with the players so
really this bag going back to the coop
and I think about if 2k one liked what I
have to do managing community you have
to build my base like I have to go into
missions how does it look on coop so
what we wanted to do is make coop really
simple we don't want a whole lot of like
set up your party mechanics and
invitations and joins what you do is you
can always just jump into your friends
game it's drop and drop out multiplayer
but we also have this really cool
mechanic where when you're playing the
game you can register to say I'm willing
to help people
and then somebody else if they're
playing whether they're your friend or
not if they get in trouble they can
shoot a flare gun and you get a beacon
it says hey someone's in trouble
and you can hit that little Xbox button
and you jump right in and you're there
to help them out
and so it really gives it a feeling of
like a community helping community which
is really the heart and soul of the game
stated a k2 is a game of humans working
together to overcome the apocalypse and
the multiplayer mechanics really support
that well to be able to get our hands on
the game yes spring 2018 we can't wait
[Music]
thank you so much for coming in right
now it's time for another brand-new
trailer let's take a look at World of
Tanks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when the blockade began in 1940
be safe but the Soviets had other ideas
one December day is all it took for the
fragile peace to shattered and once
again the streets were filled with war
are our stories
what's your turn
[Music]
Wow that looks so good and as you just
saw we're so excited to announce the
launch of xbox live arena tournaments
for world of tanks kicking off on the
22nd of august with user generated
online tournaments and wargaming
sponsored team tournaments joining
arenas in September now let's talk
controllers now for those who don't know
Xbox design lab is a website where you
can go and design your own personal
controller using overwhelm everything is
customizable including the gripstic and
triggers and we're very proud to
announce today that the service is
expanding to over 20 additional European
countries yes
now I designed my own and spent four day
I would say an estimation on agonizing
over my trigger buttons that's an entire
day but here it is I wanted to show it
to you because it's basically my dream
controller look at this little beauty I
wish I'd done my nails wait you've done
yours as well did you just do well not
really it's kind of football colors so
I've got red for Aberdeen white for
Aberdeen a bit agree for Aberdeen as
well and then blue for Scotland but most
importantly if you have a closer look up
of this one can we get closer than that
cameraman this is a special edition
Gamescom 2017 Xbox design lab controller
on the Xbox booth at Gamescom this week
so that is well super limited obviously
but you know I mean if you guys want to
know you think you know it's the best
kind of talks of the end of the show who
do you think it's got the best one let
us know on Twitter it's obviously mine
really my mine no we're gonna have like
a fight whilst you're watching on mixer
you'll be automatically entered into our
draw to win redeem codes so you can
design your very own custom controller
make sure you're signed into your
Microsoft account and you're a winner
and we'll let you know here's a video
showing off some more cool designs and
features and those countries eligible to
get involved get ready to be jealous
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my controller is definitely the best
Chris Charlie just told me everybody
were joined by Chris Charla from idea X
everybody and I believe congratulations
that our order its idea Xboxes birthday
everybody it is awesome I'm gonna eat
these Donuts hopefully so it's our
fourth anniversary so we launched idea
Xbox right here at Gamescom in 2013 and
since then it's been a fantastic ride
tons and tons of sweet games coming from
independent developers all over the
world
we've had six hundred games shipped
through the program so far including
three hundred from European developers
and definitely safe to say fans really
love these titles right oh my gosh it is
safe to say in the I have some numbers
in the last 12 months I did Xbox fans
have played more than a billion hours of
games ID at Xbox games which actually if
you do the math worth up to a hundred
thousand years of gameplay in the last
year they've unlocked 200 million
achievements or six billion gamerscore
welcome I mean it's pretty cool it's
awesome I just want to say I really
contributed a lot of these times Thank
You number but yeah congratulations on
that one big achievement you must have
big plans for the future absolutely we
have just tons and tons of games coming
we've got more than 225 hundred studios
with dev kits right now an Xbox dev kits
Xbox 1x dev kits and they are working on
more than 1500 different games right now
and I've been playing around with
creators program recently as well really
cool I mean kind of fulfills the promise
that we made when we first launched the
Xbox that anybody was going to be able
to make a game so we've got games
obviously from big giant you know
triple-a you know publishers we've got
games from fantastic independent
developers and now we've opened up Xbox
to anybody who wants to make a game
anyone can use to retail Xbox one
download free software from Microsoft
free software from the internet make a
game and ship
on Xbox one so whether you're a
professional whether you're student
hobbyist a maker an experimenter
somebody who just wants to goof around
anyone can get their game on Xbox one
now
excellent now I know you love all idea
Xbox titles like they are your children
give it give us something that you're
really excited about it coming up in the
future I do love all of them yeah
there's some great ones coming so first
of all cuphead which is a little bit
more about is coming September 29th
strange Brigade from rebellion it's
gonna be awesome mr. Billy next week
we've got path of Exile shipping it's
been in beta but it's gonna ship next
week and then Raiders have broken planet
and so many more including player in
those battlegrounds which we are super
excited about yeah it was great to see
Brendan on the stream earlier yeah
definitely and you guys can play it
actually at the booth at Gamescom as
well as thank you so much for coming
make sure you take those donuts yeah so
right now let's take a look at some of
those awesome idea Xbox game coming
first to Xbox from the idea Xbox program
in the next year world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now it's time to set sail with the guys
from see if these let's have a look what
adventures they've got in storm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this one we're joined by Joanie and
dibbens from rare so we last for the
game at e3 so what's been going on since
then updates and news given to me indeed
so yes so obviously three we showed the
magic of a going on adventures with your
friends in a pirate world shared with
other crews are going on their own
adventures which was which was super
cool but we've been hard at work since
then and so coming to games got moving
in a completely new build and we are
going to be on the show floor having
Xbox and for the first time Windows 10
PC on the show for two there's a little
hidden message in there in that by
having Xbox and PC on the show floor
we're announcing cross play for the
first time so no asterisks no small
print is literally in our shared world
you are with people from multiple
devices so very excited about that
you're breaking down barriers but it is
genuinely a magical experience plus play
right it's and when you send an email to
the whole team it was the first time I
played it I was at home on my xbox and I
joined in a couple of guys from the the
studio and they were playing on PC and
it was just seamless why you couldn't
even tell the difference and and the
I've never done that before in a game
and and it was it was literally a
magical experience that and you know we
have people in our community that have
been playing on xbox or been playing on
PC and they've kind of made friends in
the forums and in the community but
they've yet to play together and so for
the first time during games comedy self
we flick the switch too much injustice
to our services team because they work
very hard but then won't actually came
to testing it just worked and and
actually that that allowed us to really
focus on the PC version so we want to
know more about come here with 21 by 9
with an unlocked framerate and we've got
that on the show floor then we've also
got 4k running at 60 frames a second
because we knew that that was super
important we want to in early 2018 we
want to bring the PC game that players
and we felt that one of those
expectations is to be day and date right
is that we don't want the game to be at
least after on PC like we've come here
to say the cross play the PC side like
it's just all together all in the same
day my little crew who should I be what
kind of characters what kind of people
should be looking for to make the best
kind of pirate squad goals a real mix
right I need someone on the wheel
something the Crowsnest someone drinking
flying into that is that we want players
to encounter like different player types
right everyone's different in one place
if only everyone has a kind of part of
the ship that I tend to go to the crow's
nest a lot I know you tend to take the
wheel yeah so we're just Saints people
like you know come to see our thieves
calm forward slash insider and just sign
up and join us in our technical alpha
because we have a hundred thousand
people playing this week yeah and that's
clear so from Tuesday to Saturday during
games when we call players at home in
the technical our for going to be
playing cross play together
so one of the funniest things that
you've seen in the world because there
are some crazy I think it's the
creativity of what people do with the
tools we give them so like I was playing
with some strangers in our alpha and one
I was playing with the instrument and
somebody started using a spade is like a
percussion instrument hitting it on the
floor of the deck and you can hit
different parts and and it was just
amazing I've started taking more and
more players doing this in the community
now yeah so it's just like we thought
brand-new features two games come and
one of the new features is you can now
be sick in a bucket and then use that
bucket on other people really tactical
puke it's an important feature
[Laughter]
blinded and then you get your Cutlass
out inside we got 20,000 plus or more
than that now yeah it'll probably be
ticking out and right as we speak
everybody will get a chance to play the
game prior to beliefs as well if you're
in an insider everyone that's our
commitment to the Emmys and you can be
sick in a bucket and everyone will love
you for it
unlike a house party we've got loads of
exclusives our big news to come so stay
tuned but first it's time for that
minecraft news we've been teasing a
little bit about so let's take a look
world premiere when our developers
introduced redstone to Minecraft we had
no idea what it would unleash you felt
bigger better and smarter things than
anything we imagined in honor of your
creativity we've come up with an
intricate design of our own
dirt grass redstone
combined in a limited-edition form like
you've never seen before for the
adventurers the crafters and those of
you who just love dirt
is for you we can't wait to see what you
do next
[Music]
so this is the first time I have this
really great console in front of me and
I'm almost yes I touch it
it's the Minecraft Xbox one s limited
edition and joining me today is 958 from
a minecraft team thank you so much for
coming thanks for having me and may I
say first I love your earrings oh I
thank you little creepers in there
perfect so this is really a beauty let's
talk about this oh we are so glad to
finally be able to talk about this it
has been a labor of love of the entire
team the Minecraft team the Xbox team
all coming together to create this
obviously inspired by the iconic grass
block from minecraft yes yeah so you've
got the grass block on the front but
that's not all this is the first retail
console that has a transparent casing
and we took advantage of that to put in
a little Minecraft flare we have the
redstone circuitry on the inside so that
will light up when you turn on the
controller so I'm right here that's
going to light up
it's got custom minecraft sounds on
startup when you put in a disc and it
comes with the beautiful creeper
controller yes let's talk about those
durable controls I'm just gonna give you
the creeper one this one comes was a
bumble right yes alright and this one is
extra yes so also another iconic mob
from Minecraft you've got the pig and
it's not just the design on the front
but there are some little Easter eggs
hidden in these controllers for
Minecraft fans you've got the Minecraft
font on the buttons and on the back
we've got TNT for the creeper in a
little pig's tail and then they'll fix
it I love the pig tails
if you could choose one like would you
choose one or what you'd be like oh I
think that you can absolutely so so how
easy was it to design this Wow I think
we've wanted to do something like this
for a long time but all of the thought
and detail that went into this obviously
took some time oh definitely
but just to be sure what's in this
bundle let's talk about that so you get
the console you get the creeper
controller and you get the Minecraft
and that is the better together update
that includes the cross-platform play
and servers for our console players also
get a free month of realms and the pack
that includes custom skins and textures
so it is a full bundle for the minecraft
fan so and when can we get a hands on
this bundle when is the pre-order
happening so the pre-order starts right
now oh and the bundle will be available
at retail in October 3rd
Wow thank you so much for this
information Megan and thank you so much
for coming and it's in fact if you're
watching right now and mixer and you're
signed in via Microsoft account one
lucky fan is going to it one of these
very limited edition consoles and
controllers so you're just gonna be
picked at random so just keep an eye out
on your inbox and you could be the lucky
winner so coming up we'll be jumping
into a stylized cartoon and world with
cuphead but first it's time for will
premier gameplay trailer from our
friends at Warner Brothers interactive
entertainment check out the highly
anticipated Middle Earth shadow of war
world premiere
to the young love
there are summoning death
[Music]
what have we unleashed
this hoe is beyond us killer Brembo
yes bigger and better in every way than
shadow of Mordor I can't wait to play
that and because we don't want anything
to become come between you and the
bright Lord and if you can't wait to get
hands-on Middle Earth shadow of war
we're pleased to announce that these
Xbox one air shadow of war bundles will
be available this October both bundles
include an xbox one s with either a 500
gigabyte or a one terabyte hard drive
you get Middle Earth shadow of war
including the bonus in-game items
legendary champions war party and the
epic sword of Dominion as you read this
you get an Xbox wireless controller you
also get a one month Xbox game per
subscription and you get a 14 day Xbox
Live Gold trial and if you want to see
more on shadow of war then tune in on
Tuesday at 9:30 p.m. German time for the
shadow of war a legendary war party I
will be there hosting and I'm gonna
gather all my orcs around me what do you
get if you combine contra ok with super
mario world yes and 1930s hand-drawn
cartoons RS i know you actually get cut
head shall we
[Music]
every time I see it I just want to know
more about it about music so we're
joined by Maya from studio mvhr great to
have you with us thank you so much for
coming in and I'm super excited by this
game probably more than most other games
just cuz it's just so fresh it feels so
which is weird because it's quite old
style but it feels so fresh and
different so what's happened since
what's happened to d3 yeah well thanks
for having us here we're very excited to
be at Gamescom this year with a brand
new demo so we're wrapping up
development right now and as you are
probably aware a cup it is a run-and-gun
platformer where you can run duck jump
shoot Perry we also have other levels
where you can play as shmup okay Julia's
gonna talk to you in a second about the
animation stuff I'm really keen to know
more about how the gameplay works and
what the kind of gameplay influences are
on cuphead right so we were heavily
inspired by a games of the late 80s
Early 90s of retro retro games so
gunstar heroes contra Mega Man games an
archetype we were talking about earlier
yeah so there are some levels where you
do a play as a schmuck using the force I
always thinks that Zen Norman you can
actually process it it's just really
really quick but it's just it's you're
on that you're on that zone so we have
to talk about the actual style of it as
well because I mean talk about the
process in creating the look of cockpit
because it's it's pretty unique yeah so
every single game every single frame in
the game is hand drawn with pencil and
paper and it had inked as well on paper
so also all the backgrounds are
watercolor paintings and there's nearly
three hours of custom jazz music custom
jazz yes like my other everything in
this game which is unusual for a video
game has been hand crafted yeah there's
like real artisanship going into this
right yeah we really wanted to maintain
be authentic to the era of 1930s I mean
like older cartoons were
a little bit weird a little bit strange
and obviously you know seeing cuphead
there's you know there's it's very much
like that was that kind of always the
the idea from the start to kind of keep
that most definitely most definitely it
was a dry for us especially to it was
that surrealistic approach to animating
where there were no boundaries yeah so
we really loved the idea where Felix the
Cat could you know rip off his tail and
use as matches like something on fire so
that was the draw to basically making
very wacky crazy bosses and enemies that
sort of sounds like when you say it like
that that sounds a little bit horrific
in some sort of way doesn't it but it
makes sense of that era that was super
weird very resourceful as well I know I
mean we're seeing gameplay on screen
here now you can totally see that that
old-school shoot-'em-up gameplay now I
grew up on those games and I remember
them being tough and punishing their
kind of difficulty level yeah so it was
designed to be challenging but we also
have some modern nods to make it fair
so your progression is saved so every
time that you sit down to play the game
you're not starting all over again
yeah you have infinite lives and when
playing in co-op you also have the
ability to revive your partner if they
die off-screen if you catch them while
they're floating off-screen yeah we have
also designed the game with multiple
modes so there is easy and normal mode
and and then once you complete the game
in normal mode we unlock new game+ for
elites which always sounds really
friendly but I think is it you can
actually switch between the different
kind of difficulties for each level yes
so you can play a normal mode for one
level and if you're if you don't have
much experience in the next one you can
switch it back down to simple just you
get completely beaten you're like I'm
not quite a new game I can't wait to
wait in coach co-op that's gonna be
great right yes yes no definitely it's
it's a little more chaotic on screen
it's a bullet hell but like I said
you're your partner can pop in and pop
out at any time by pressing any key
throughout the level the boss health it
does scale up
a little bit when your mode but it also
scales back down if you've lost your
partner great okay I love the fact that
one of our biggest cheers at our e3
press briefing was for the release date
of remind everyone yes so cubby comes
out on September 29th on Xbox one
Windows 10 in steam excellent and people
here at Gamescom this week are going to
be able to play on the Xbox booth as
well so that's fantastic Maya thank you
so much for thank you
right still to come on the show we'll
hear from Major Nelson who will be
unveiling something very close to the
Xbox team's heart I'm just checking I'm
just making sure but first it's time for
another world premiere gameplay trailer
world premiere by joining this exciting
mission to Mars you will be part of
shaping the future of humanity you'll
get to travel to an inspiring beautiful
you research and utilize state of the
art technology
to construct the dynamic network with
extraordinary facilities
you develop and sustain
an innovative self-sufficient habitat
you live in a prosperous and present
community
the relationship between humans and
technology
and just so you know the dangers that
you might heard of have been exactly
[Music]
Mars is really a very safe place
colonize Mars and discover her secrets
with minimal casualties
all right some more world from your
gameplay there for you that is surviving
Mars I loved city skylines it's great to
get first look at gameplay of paradoxes
new game set on Mars now it's almost the
end of the show but we've got something
really special to show you
you might have heard a little bit about
it already but I wanted to officially
introduce you to a very special new
member of the Xbox family world premiere
two years ago we started on this dirty
you told us you wanted power
this is absolutely the culmination of
all of your feedback and something that
we think will truly move xboxone forward
[Music]
[Music]
so there you go ever on the Xbox 1x
project
Scorpio edition and now even though we
couldn't be here with us we just had to
have Major Nelson on the show so we
thought he would be the perfect person
to unbox this beauty take it away Larry
world premiere hi rahem Xbox Live's
Major Nelson really excited to share
this with you this is the Xbox one X
project Scorpio edition that we are
announcing today and will be available
for pre-order today as well now I have
these special white gloves which are
gonna allow me to dig in and do an
unboxing but I want to show you the Box
first
because this is beautiful this is the
beautiful packaging which leans into the
heritage of Xbox here we see the Xbox
screen for those fans that have been
with us for a while they're gonna notice
the X on the front it looks like the
original Xbox doesn't it of course
earlier this year we announced original
Xbox coming to back impact you can kind
of see it hint it in this xbox 1x super
limited edition packaging so what do you
say we jump into it
let's take a look at what we have in the
box of course we have a trial for game
pass an Xbox Live Gold will be included
in this box over here you'll find the
stand which I've already got attached
this box over here we're going to
include the controller batteries are
included a high-speed 4k capable HDMI
cable and then we have the console but
not just any console this is the world's
most powerful console 4k gaming 6
teraflops this thing as you know is a
beast look at the front look at this
beautiful graphic design we have the
Xbox screen on both the console as well
as the controller project Scorpio
edition this is lovely
alright now we get a good shot at this
let me spin it around here so you can
see the beautiful beautiful design on
the front the precision and the dots is
kind of a gradient all the way down
again heritage showing the power this is
the world's most powerful console and
you need a design to show that off and
that's what the project Scorpio Edition
does you can see it right here look how
beautiful it is and here we have the
controller you can see it says project
Scorpio on the front of course the Xbox
green is there which is great to see for
folks that know the Xbox screen with
these beautiful premium buttons now I
also want to point out that all your
existing Xbox one controllers will work
perfectly with Xbox one X and of course
the Xbox one X Project Scorpio edition
isn't it beautiful alright let's turn it
around and take a look at the ports back
here of course if you have an Xbox one s
you'll already recognize the ports
they're in precisely the same order as
your Xbox one s so you can drop this
into your home entertainment system
unplug it from the Xbox one s plug it
into the Xbox one X we're gonna make it
easy to move all your content over and
you're gonna be ready to go what's
really cool is we have some design
touches back here as well you'll notice
that the HDMI out has a little little
bump on it so you know when you're
feeling back there you know exactly what
port to plug it into everything is
exactly the same it's gonna be very very
familiar and that's a look at the Xbox
one X project Scorpio edition now
everything of a standard edition is
included in the project Scorpio edition
but here you get this beautiful graphic
you get the xbox green and this
exclusive stand now I'm happy to share
it is available for pre-order today so
get your pre-order in because once it's
gone this is gonna be gone for good
my name is Larry herb Xbox Live's Major
Nelson thanks for watching
[Music]
you know entertained by the way Larry
nice gloves I feel like he should have
like made it appear and disappear like a
magician console well I am kind of
annoyed that he got his hands on a
project score field before me as oh well
you're gonna be third in line cause
right now I'm touching it what do you
like most about okay good I love the
fact that we've acknowledged how much
our fans loved project Scorpio as a name
I think it's great that we've we've
pulled that out we've put it on the
front of that xbox Xbox one X is a cool
name but I'm gonna miss Project Scorpio
you don't need to miss project Scorpio
anymore there's like a you know a
temporary name no one ever good get rid
of that I really do love the stand
though because everybody asked also when
we had the Xbox 1x and now segways it's
lying when there's a stand coming so
there it is and it's got really nice
that gradient on the side from grey to
black at the top as well really subtle
but really really nice it is beautiful
as well so get your pre-orders in they
are alive right now
and unfortunately that is it from Xbox
at Gamescom life but this really is just
the beginning of our week here in
Cologne if you're in Cologne make sure
you come and see us on the Xbox booth
and also on the mixer booth you'll be
able to get hands-on with big games like
cut paired and hands-on with Xbox one X
and everything we've showed you tonight
you'll be able to design one of those
Xbox design lab controllers it's going
to be amazing and of course don't forget
myself and Greg ray sorry we'll be back
tomorrow at 9 p.m. Germans toffee and
Pacific for the age of empires at
Gamescom live we'll be traveling through
time
I'm sorry I was told there's gonna be
reverb to me that sound good and of
course there'll be a huge huge exclusive
announcement don't miss it it's gonna be
great yes you definitely don't want to
miss it and I know that eight of
vampires are going to be thrilled at
what we are going to share them mm-hmm
oh yeah thanks to all my guests I was
like tonight's show what a great way to
kick start of Gamescom I'm super excited
I'm excited for tomorrow I'm buzzing it
before we all rush off the border our
project scorpion consoles now we're
gonna leave you with a little reminder
of all the great games you can play over
the next few months on Xbox
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys and that Rupp's wraps up the
gamescom 2017 Microsoft press conference
I'm Justin hey well joined here by
Michael hi um yep that's me and we're
gonna be discussing what they announce
what they showed if you'd like to share
your thoughts with us we're broadcasting
live on GameSpot YouTube and twitch we'd
love to hear your thoughts and your
questions so Michael I guess the big
thing out of that if you want to call it
a big thing other than it lasting an
hour and a half was the project Scorpio
Xbox 1x their their closing of course
you're always gonna close with what one
of your big things are pre-orders are
open now and there's a project Scorpio
Xbox one X move the needle for you or
like oh my god I gotta get an Xbox one X
now there's it says project Scorpio on
it I mean it I feel like it's just
different ways to market your new
console you know get people hyped up
like oh we got this project Scorpio
branding then they have like for the 1s
they have the Microsoft one in the
shadow of mordor bundle it's like it's
nothing too crazy it's you know it's
kind of what you would expect for a
console launch like all we have these
different limited edition or got special
prints on it I mean that's not what I've
got hyped up for I think even a you know
the bigger story if we're gonna talk
about Xbox 1x was the full list of games
that get Xbox and 1x enhancements oh we
kind of already knew there was gonna be
like a ton of games that are gonna get
if not all like all the enhancements
from the new console but now that like
we've solidified like these games will
get them so exciting but that story is
still going through this games come I at
e3 I wasn't convinced what is Xbox 1x
gonna do that's gonna make people say I
need to get an Xbox 1x and watching the
games come thing I'm still not sold on
what really makes this that incredibly
different I don't have a 4k TV at home
like I'm still you know I I have a nice
TV it's ok but it doesn't do 4k and I
still feel like watching this if I don't
have a 4k TV I don't know why I would be
inclined to do it do you feel like
that's different yeah
I don't I don't think anything changed
here at Gamescom like I felt like I mean
this is part of the discussion - is that
what we saw here at Gamescom was kind of
a reminder of what we saw at e3 like
there is I mean aside from a few new
things it was a reminder that you know
one X is coming out it's doing all these
different things like they've pretty
much said all they could possibly say
but going back to you know it's like
you're not gonna find any new reason to
get a 1x if you haven't been kids
convinced already so I mean you know
it's for you know people have 4k TVs or
you will still get enhancements I think
we've discussed this before with super
sampling and anisotropic filtering all
this other stuff that you'll get yeah
Michael you're a tech editor so you have
a much probably better insight than I do
into how this is going to affect games
from a technological standpoint because
I you know I basically plug in my
controller and that's the extent of
knowing how any technology works I mean
it'll look nice things will look nice I
it's still you know we have the list of
all the games that are gonna get
enhancements but we're not 100% sure on
what the enhancements will be so you
know it's up to the devs ultimately what
they want to do with their game so you
might get better frame rates you might
get you know a ton of super sampling and
it will look like really crispy and it
still might run on the same frame rate
so that's still unclear I mean we you
know there's since there's like over a
hundred games that we'll get
enhancements it's almost impossible for
them to know right off the bat like how
these games are going to be enhanced but
yeah I mean now think about this from a
tech perspective it's you know if you're
not if you're not into you know
high-fidelity graphics or if you don't
if you don't really care about that
stuff if you just want to play games the
1x really isn't for you and going back
to games come what we just saw today
like you know I didn't expect a new
reason like them to come out and say hey
you know there's like a new reason for
you to look at this Xbox 1x it's just
kind of like here we're reminding you
that we're coming out soon and here's
some special editions so it's not that
big video yeah so we're gonna hit a lot
more of there the other announcements of
the things that we saw but kind of
speaking specifically to what Xbox does
that police station isn't necessarily
gonna have as much strength that it is
that cross platform that cross play
because Microsoft has talked a big game
about making games work across Xbox
across PC I'm making that architecture
whole and we got a little bit of that
with C of these so this is gonna be
another cross play game and I feel like
we need a lot more of that yeah
definitely definitely I mean I say what
you want about Co thieves whether you're
hyped up for it or not the fact that you
know they said you know we're just gonna
have we're gonna have cross play between
PC and Xbox one players I think that's
such an important thing for me moving
forward as you know you have all these
different platforms you know how you're
gonna sustain a player base there's so
many damn games out now how do you
maintain a solid player base like well
off the top of my head is like make
everything cross play you know you don't
want to you have even called duty
infinite warfare did that was peace with
PC for awhile I think it was like why
from the Windows Store you play with
people on the Windows Store you can buy
on Steam like your do you divide people
so much that you know you essentially
cut your game short like its life span
short so them saying like you know
they've been hyping up see if these for
a long time to you know we've we've been
seeing this game for like three years so
I mean they're putting a lot raters
putting a lot of effort into this and
you want to make it last as long as
possible so break down the barriers and
have everyone play with everyone and you
know this isn't a game that's gonna like
really lose any you know parody with
keyboard and mouse and controller
players cuz like you know it's kind of
that that cartoony art style kinda
cel-shaded it's not like you need to
play this on yeah on PC over over
console yeah I mean the with Gears award
you couldn't do versus yeah between PC
and Xbox which is understandable because
you know you could get wreck someone
who's using a controller if you got a
keyboard a mouse but yeah this game I
think is you know it's a step forward
with breaking down the barriers for that
and it's a type of game that would
benefit greatly from it because there's
like you know I'm not gonna like be like
Oh unless there are like snipers and
stuff like that you know I really see
the problem with having controller and
keyboard mouse playing the same time we
got to see a little bit more Co thieves
as well that I hadn't seen before
personally haven't been really playing
in the alpha
but there was a part there were there
was a ghost I didn't know this was a
part of the game that I I assumed when
you die I guess maybe this is a way to
get it reintroduce into it but does that
mean that there might be ghost ships
that you might still be able to keep
playing with players after after you
died like they'd be kind of cool kind of
like in racing games where you finish a
lap or you can raise someone else's
ghost car you can like it's still good
to mess with somebody's game yeah I
don't know I mean I've been payed
attention to like the gameplay aspect of
CA thieves ever since III because like
nothing really news come out but I mean
there's a lot there's a lot of
interesting things that this is doing
you know rare you know they putting
their all their efforts into this
multiplayer only game so you know I want
to want to see where it can go
especially with you know a bigger player
base now yeah so this is probably one of
the bigger exclusives that people are
gonna be hyped up about but another one
for a specific audience is Fortson got
to see a little bit more forza you're
definitely a racing fan you know much
more than me I I think the extent of my
racing knowledge is a Mario Kart that's
not bad but you you know cars yes like
you know real cars they drive a real car
and real life amen yeah I drive a real
car now so what was your takeaway from
Forte I mean again yeah I don't really
think that there was anything new or
groundbreaking that we saw but you know
reminding people that you know forces
because then we have a Forza every year
and you know you can get burnt out on
even though they alternate before
between horizon and motorsport from
based on what I what I seen from
motorsport is you know the the real like
high-end cars is super fast cars that's
that stuff is exciting and we got to see
a little bit more of that I'm just more
with with simulation racing games I'm
always looking for like more RPG
elements you know how am I getting back
customizing your race crew upgrading
your car specifically like tuning it
very specifically with like camber and
suspension and you're the type of tires
you use that I mean that's the kind of
stuff that we go I always want to see
out of a racing game I sure that will
get that
Forza Motorsport seven and they also
showed people racing in semi
tractor-trailers oh yeah they're really
yeah this is a I feel like that's really
going after that German audience in the
whole this is Gamescom this is part of
the Europe and I feel like that's
something that's gonna play better in
Europe yeah I mean you've got because
they they have to mix it up with these
sim racing games that take place on
tracks so you know having little tidbits
like that driving track there on out of
course you know it's they gotta switch
it up somehow because this is the
seventh one in the series
and so one of the things that we were
expecting going into this is that they
would have a large focus on third party
games the Microsoft doesn't have a lot
of exclusives especially going to this
holiday this is something that has to
focus on what we have coming up now and
that's what we got we started off the
show looking at assassin's creed
assassin's creed origin story this is
our first look at that cinematic trailer
yeah what'd you think yeah I I've kind
of fell off Assassin's Creed after - I
love - a lot I fell off a little bit
after three and I like Black Flag but
I'm super into it we soured it so much
for me like I'm ready to go back to
origins I hope that it reinvigorates
that love for the French yeah and that's
kind of what I got out of this is it was
a reminder that you know Assassin's
Creed digs into historical figures in a
sometimes thoughtful way or at least a
very fun way like Cleopatra and I think
like Ptolemy he's gonna be in it like
we're gonna have some math up in here
man like build up here like when they
are showing the time-lapse of building
pyramids like thinking about in
historical context like I really want to
play this and see where they go with it
so I mean the cinematic trailer is going
to show me anything new on gameplay but
again it's it's got me hyped up and it's
reminding me so you don't think and do
that at the end of that trailer when he
like grabs the bow and arrow with his
feet and then shoots the guy in the to
do that in the game I'm I don't know
chance right maybe it's in that maybe
it's in the skill tree I don't know
that's that'd be tight what I mean you
said you've fell off no I loved to to is
probably one of my favorite games that
is in
my top 10 games of all time I did it was
amazing oh yeah and like I thought we
had a good build-up after that like
there were lots of nice additions until
we got to three
yeah and three really just killed my
love for that franchise like I went back
a little bit I know people like Black
Flag I thought it was good but it didn't
recapture it in quite the same way and
I'm really hope origins does and that
the RPG trappings they have around this
like that's really exciting to me like
that's what I loved about too is that it
felt not just like an action game but it
but it also felt like an RPG and like I
get to control the city and control this
world build up my character
yeah my origins might be excited yeah I
think that they have to because this
setting lends itself so well to those
types of things I mean whether or not
you're like trying to build up a side
army to send off on like side missions
or like even just like the combat and
you know skill trees and you know trying
to shoot someone a bow and arrow with
your feet like that like this stuff like
that like if if that says something in
this trailer that you when they showed
that you know I
what kind of directions you can go with
the gameplay like we did see the
gameplay at e3 and a couple of our
colleagues played it too so I'm excited
for that but there's still I still want
to see more I still want to see more
more depth than you know more story
except like something exciting with the
historical context push B to shoot with
fleet yeah so like how complicated is
that gonna be to pull off is it gonna be
like a QuickTime event or is it gonna be
like button sequins now that's that's
not gonna be in the game one weird thing
one thing that I was a little bit
surprised about with this presentation
was Jurassic world evolution oh yes
you started with dinosaurs I love
diamonds who doesn't love dinosaurs the
dinosaurs may I
and then it's Jurassic world alright
this I there have been a lot of really
bad Jurassic Park games I'm willing to
give this a benefit of the doubt and
it's a park simulator yeah no no what I
was expecting
Masek franchise where you expect you
know you play through the part the parks
you going crazy you gotta go kill some
Tyrannosaurus right play as Chris Pratt
or make yeah
spread yeah crisp crisp bread is a great
here he's a great foil has great funny
lines or you're in the park as dinosaurs
you got to escape and kill everybody o
Orakei could what if it was like some
like evolved game you're like yeah you
can play as one dinosaur he got like
three dudes try to take him down but
instead we have a park simulator this is
this is interesting that I'm not I I
want to try it out I'm curious yeah I'm
it was not what I was expecting so it's
like I I definitely see how this fits
tight games calm audience where you're
gonna have a lot more simulation where
you're gonna have a lot more of these
world building type games and I'm
curious to see how this is gonna play
out that's not necessarily the kind of
game that I think about is something I
want to play on console yeah well
someone in twitch tab mentioned asked if
this is on mobile already and it's funny
that they asked that because that's a
that's a that's the first thing I
thought of when I saw them when they
dropped the building to reveal what the
game was I was like this kind of does
look like a mobile game I mean maybe
it's just like okay well have it on Xbox
one it if you want to play that but I
mean this this kind of I mean it's cool
that they're coming out with this but
these types of games I don't really want
to play with a controller this isn't me
being like mr. PC boy over here but you
know I know it does nothing it doesn't
really do anything for me honestly mr.
PC boy I don't that's interesting title
one thing I do want to play with my
controller though is shadow of war yes I
don't like I feel like I've seen so much
gameplay this I don't know what's new
and what's not but every time I see it I
get a little bit more hyped I I'm ready
to play this this was this was our
GameSpot Game of the Year 2014 2014 and
to be fair for games right but still I I
think this is a well deserved game of
the year and it's like it's good it has
a lot more competition in 2017 what do
you think about the game I mean it's it
it's all about the Nemesis system you
know the net when the Nemesis system
came out that's one of the biggest
reasons why it was so important in 2014
and I kind of expected more games to
follow suit like I was gonna see some so
of Nemesis system and games following
but we didn't get that much so they can
either have something in place that's
you know very similar or evolved I mean
we did just a little bit of it yeah we
saw a sudden evolution and how it's been
building not just the Nemesis system but
you have like basically nemesis army
yeah so it's it's a lot bigger in scope
I just I really want to like feel it and
like see how it comes out in practice
but uh like other than that like you
really liked shadow of Mordor but what
more is I mean did you play it at e3 or
did you know okay like what more would
you want out of it when you when you
play this game like other than an
evolution of its Nemesis system what
else do you want so I'm ready to just
dive back into this world I'm really
curious where they take the story cuz
shadow of war did a great job with that
if there was one failing that I think
that shadow a shadow of mordor had it's
that every area you went to kind of felt
the same then I wanted more variety in
where I was exploring because I I
thought traversing the world was great I
thought combat was great it was just a
really fun take on what in other games
can be kind of slow where it's kind of
slowly dripping you slow dripping this
ability to to fight and to traverse this
world and I thought Sheldon Mordor had
that great balance of letting you feel
almost godlike in your powers but not
making it so simple and so easy that
you're just gonna destroy everything
so shadow of war I really like to see
new areas new places and like I'm really
excited about the new enemies like
fighting a Balrog the Balrog looks crazy
like that looks really cool yeah so I
mean this is an Xbox conference so
Microsoft I can play on Xbox one I will
well that's one of the beautiful things
about working at a site like GameSpot is
that we get to see and try things out on
different consoles and as someone who
works the site like I have all three I
have a PC I haven't intend to switch ps4
Xbox one and so I'm really gonna go with
what game looks the best is for
something like this it's not multiplayer
centric so I don't have to worry about
where my friends are gonna be playing I
just want to get the best experience for
the least amount of work and my PC is
not the best so there's a good chance
they're all for this I'll be going with
ps4
or Xbox one it'll depend on which one
looks the best which one performs the
best is there some incentive that I
would get outside of outside of you know
having it look great on a 4k which I
have that that shadow were uh Xbox 1s
bundle mmm that'd look pretty dope so
one thing that I do want to play with my
friends though
is gonna be player unknown battleground
yeah it's a little bit on PC and I suck
at it so bad I'm so I've never had a
chicken dinner you trash me never gotten
chicken dinner have you got chicken
dinner Oh ass give me I'm asking you
have you gotten chicken dinner you
didn't answer that questions
you even got ass yeah I'd be getting
check dinners all day boy so so are you
gonna play this on Xbox one that's like
this is a console get for Microsoft like
I don't not of course on the level of
something like minecraft but as far as
something that has got that zeitgeist of
what players are playing Microsoft
publishing this that's a big deal that
isn't that is a very big deal you know
because I have I've played it on PC
extensively everyone in the office is
taken by this game my friends at home
this is like I get to spend time with my
friends at home by playing this game and
we have so many moments where we're just
like laughing our ass off or like we're
just sweating bullets because we're a
little we're the last team it gets the
other team and there's the really small
circle if you don't know what pub G or
play it on play your unknowns
battlegrounds is it's a battle royale
type game so it's really intense
especially as you get down to the last
players and speaking of like bringing it
back to what we saw today with Microsoft
and bring it to console is also another
reminder that you know this is coming to
console this is coming to Xbox which is
incredible because we haven't we've had
on PC we've had so many of these battle
royale type games yeah that it's almost
when this came out was like oh cool this
is a more polished more fun version of
this but for console players they
haven't had the experience of this game
so they've hadn't had a great experience
oh the way that pub G has yeah yeah
these kind of but they're always a
little bit yeah nothing pub G isn't it
has some jank of course but like you
know because it's already huge
phenomenon and you know people who
aren't on PC who have been hearing about
this but have you know an Xbox one there
there
like whoa I really want to get into this
I really want to see what the hype is
about and this is like really cool that
it's coming out for Xbox one and I did
see it when we're looking at it right
now and you know I mean I've always
preferred before I don't know if this is
totally indicative of what the game is
yeah some of the some of these shots
that'll never happen there's some really
funny moments in that game is some
really intense moments it's it's really
something special and it's even like
better that you know I'm not gonna pull
I'm gonna keep playing on PC but I'm
happy that you know this is has reached
a you know such a height that it's like
oh we're gonna really sound console and
everyone's super hyped up for it so well
uh well for you like are you more
inclined to play it on console rather
than PC
I love playing on PC because keyboard
and mouse but I know like Nick one of
our friends here at the office he's
super hyped up to play on console
because he's played with controllers so
well it's so nice to be able to sit on
your couch you know be able to sit in
your living room because I like I know
that it's not hard to get a decent PC
set up in my living room but I've I've
tried so many different ways and I'm
just it's never quite as comfortable as
that can that controller experience and
then you have a game like pub G you have
these first-person shooters where if I'm
not playing with a mouse and keyboard I
I feel at a disadvantage I'm not as good
on a controller as I am mouse and
keyboard
I like having everything come together
where where everybody is gonna be on
controller or a mouse and keyboard so I
still I sit at my desk when I play
overwatch I sit on my couch when I play
something like Call of Duty and that's
why Pub like I'd love to be able to sit
and play pop G in my living room just
with a controller knowing everybody else
has that same right limitation right
right right yeah that's that's perfectly
understandable I mean and that's really
cool that you could do that now and
someone did mention in the in the
comments that yes this is coming to ps4
as well but I think it's coming to X but
it's an console launch launch exclusives
for Xbox so welcome to ps4 later that's
been said when it is I don't know but
yeah like they sign these weird
contracts where they're not even going
to be able to talk about how and when
it's coming to these other consoles like
we saw the same thing with Tomb Raider
several years back where
everyone was super cagey when they're
like yeah it is a console launch
exclusive on xbox like what does that
mean we can't tell you like woo Lee I
don't think they're allowed to say which
is a little bit ridiculous but yeah
coming on console coming on I expects
one X like that's that it's coming there
earlier is gonna be not I don't think a
turning point I don't necessarily think
that something's gonna shift consoles
but if you're someone who is on the
fence or if you own an Xbox one and the
ps4 like this might be the kind of thing
we're lucky all my friends are playing
this maybe destiny level like because
now we are you know we're also coming
into destiny 2 coming up if your friends
aren't necessarily gonna make that jump
over to destiny 2 maybe they're looking
for a new multiplayer experience pub G
could fill that fo yeah yeah I think so
and it's for Xbox one it's gonna be
released this year which is kind of is
pretty big deal because you know we're
gonna it's gonna be able it's gonna be
available for the holidays so maybe
that'll be able to push console sales as
well for people who you know don't want
to buy PC they want to play this on
console it's like oh well this year I
can hop on this and they'll probably
have like some holiday deals as well and
so I can go I can this is a like a
kicker for Xbox one people who are on
the fence buy Xbox one I think I believe
the ps4 one is gonna if when it comes
out it's gonna be 2018 yeah all right
there earliest yeah yeah so then this
year alone for holiday season I think
this is a this is a big you know card
that Microsoft has in their back pocket
so I think we saw a lot of great
trailers from this game cons press
conference I was a hoping for more it
was an hour and a half long it was kinda
there was a lot of fluff I didn't
necessarily need all of these softball
interviews but they were still really
good trailers except for reek or not not
totally sold on so what their this is
remastering the xbox one version with
the new xbox one version like I really
like it's the definitive version it's
not they use the word remaster which was
the wrong word to use for a game that's
already out on that same console but I
don't know I'm still well it's they
mention that this is free for people who
already in their words a record customer
but like people who already own if you
already own record that you can still
continue playing
recourse yeah well the thing was is that
a lot of recourse was felt incomplete
and I'm assuming I don't know if it's
been said already that you know this is
gonna kind of grind out those rough
edges those missing pieces of this game
because that's kind of what soured so
many people on it and on its initial
release you know you get to the get to
the near the end I don't I'm not gonna
spoil anything but like you get near the
end and it's like what's there's so many
things here that haven't haven't been
resolved like in terms of objectives and
playing like areas in the game it's like
where's the rest of this game so you
know having this you know Billy will
have high res and HDR but you know
content wise you know you should expect
this to be a more complete version some
might say the reversion that should have
been released in the first place but I'm
not sure where everyone stands on that
well so that's pretty much the Microsoft
games come press conference in a
nutshell Xbox 1x pre-orders went on sale
right now they're right at the the end
of the conference where do you stand on
Microsoft after watching this are you
hyped more did you want to pre-order the
console I mean it it kind of didn't hype
me up more than I already have been
knows you're like nah man but it was
just like I keep saying it just reminded
me like okay yeah yeah this is a Xbox
one X is kind of a big deal you know I
I'm a people like primarily a PC gamer I
love my ps4 because it has like
exclusive games and what I want
Microsoft to do well because like it's
just you know you want everyone to put
out great products cuz that's better for
all of us so competition and calm is
what drives innovation yeah and so I you
know say what you want about Xbox 1x
whether it's the price or the specs you
know I'm really excited for how it's
gonna like change the gaming landscape
if it changes it all that much you know
just knowing that you know they're
putting all these resources into this
new console and really trying to take
advantage of high-end tech and 4k and
all that stuff you know when I think
about it like as someone who's
constantly looking at the price of PC
parts you know putting together the you
know best deals of the week or like
talking about expend new video
cards that cost like four hundred five
hundred dollars you know this consoles
five hundred dollars and you're getting
the strength of a PC that would cost
like uh eight hundred to a thousand
dollars so you know the but at the same
time you're only gonna be able to play
xbox oh I like you can compare it to the
strength of a PC but your piece that's
the reason why pcs are more expense cuz
it may obviously they do more they're
more than just you know gaming machines
but you know the fact that yeah because
then that the Xbox you can say the Xbox
one was underpowered from the get-go so
it only makes sense that they come out
with a stronger version you know but
this is like a lot stronger so I'm
hopeful that you know people are
receptive to the Xbox one X because that
also means that you know if more the
more these companies do well you know
the more that you know competition is
all about competition and you know other
companies going to do even better so you
know that's exciting I you know it's
it's not exactly the products for me but
again I want to see it do well the thing
that it really comes down to and I think
that next year is gonna be the moment of
truth is what games do we get and right
I wasn't expecting any huge
announcements I wasn't expecting
anything really surprising out of
Gamescom but Microsoft has not quite
stepped up to the plate for exclusive
games and so 2018 is really the kind of
the sink-or-swim year we need yeah it's
like you need not just exclusives but
you need to say this is the reason you
want to play it because we've seen that
with previous years that even having the
exclusive is if it's not that great
especially in comparison to the
competition that's not what's gonna move
the needle you need exclusives that
people are really excited about yeah and
I feel like Sony has kind of had the
edge on Microsoft for that all 2017
definitely yeah I I agree too and like
the fact that you know crackdown got
delayed like crackdown was supposed to
be like the leading game for 2017 and I
you know I kind of more or less forgot
about crackdown as a whole but it was
like oh okay this is actually a pretty
big deal and it's gonna come this year
and then it got too late to 2018 it's
like well there was slim pickins to
begin with for Microsoft and it's like
well I guess you know with the X like
fully launched I guess 2018 is when
they're gonna make a true push for
exclusives you know maybe we'll get
new Halo game next year that would you
know hopefully push boundaries and then
we'll get crackdown 3 and we'll see a
lot of games push the hardware I mean
like what what would you expect in 2018
besides like crackdown 3 year or a new
Halo though I love surprises and I have
no imagination
I'm just enough like an empty husk of a
human so I mean what's gonna happen I
don't know I hope I'm alive in 2018
that's really one of my main goal that's
all we can have next year so I'm really
excited to see what Microsoft comes out
with next year what they're gonna do
building off the Xbox 1x if this kind of
gets that install base that they need
and I you know I'm curious about console
life cycles in general that we've talked
a little bit about that with the
previous generation and going into this
one where they've said this is no longer
even a 10-year life cycle like maybe
there's not gonna be another console
maybe it's just this constant iteration
yeah what does that mean for gamers what
does that mean for for console
manufacturers and are they actually
gonna stick to these guns are we ever
gonna see a ps5 are we gonna see an Xbox
1 X 2 ok wait what is the heading what
does that landscape even look like oh
yeah that's that's something really
interesting for me who's been paying
attention to like PC hardware and like
console launches for a long array a long
time I really have I would suspect that
it would be more of an iteration based
but like kind of iteration based
consoles but at what point do you cut
off and say like you can't play these
games on this old console anymore like
that like that was one of my least
favorite things about 360 and ps3 that's
kind of what pushed me to doing a lot
more gaming on on PC is that I don't
have access on ps3 in particular I don't
have access to all my ps3 digital
library which is ridiculous Microsoft
has made inbounds in into that in so
much of a better way that I have access
to so many more of my Xbox library of
games that I've already purchased on my
xbox one and I love that move I feel
like that's so much more consumer
friendly but you also like now you need
to prove that to me with what comes next
with that continuing support for me
purchasing purchasing games digitally
because I do that so much more than I
know I don't want physical games anymore
I want digital games I don't want
everything
just messed up my house I'm not gonna
like digital games are so much more
convenient oh yeah definitely
yeah I don't I can't speculate on where
consoles are gonna go but man my money
would be on you know iterations but
that's that's exciting that's an
exciting thing to see moving forward in
the industry and I think like Microsoft
and is kind of taking lead on that in a
way because this Xbox 1x is like really
pushing the boundaries for console
hardware and we're gonna be digging into
that a lot more here on GameSpot with
like what is the future of gaming at
2018 but especially going to this
holiday we're gonna be checking out the
Xbox one x-men it lunches will probably
be getting a review of that from Michael
hi um right here yo as well as how that
compares and stacks up to other consoles
and all of these holiday releases what
we're gonna be doing reviews of them
it's gonna be really busy review season
coming up soon very exciting man cool
and so I was just inhaled this was
Michael hi um thanks so much for joining
us and stay tuned to games become for
even more gaming coverage thank you all